let's go over angle insertion for
injections first up is intramuscular we
want to go in that muscle and you want
to go in at a 90 degree angle next is
subcutaneous we want to go in that fatty
tissue so you want to go in anywhere
between a 90 to 45 degree angle it
really depends on how much fat is under
that skin on the patient then we have
intravenous so we're targeting the vein
and you want to go in anywhere between a
15 to 30 degree angle depending on how
deep that vein is and then lastly we
have intradermal and you want to go in
anywhere between a 10 to 15 degree angle
and with this we're targeting the dermis
so just below the epidermis and how you
know you got a really good intradermal
injection is that you're going to see a
wheel or a bleb on the skin which looks
like a small bubble